The greedy approach leads to what is called a meta-server
overload. Let's understand how that happens. Let's say that
there's a whole bunch of users that are generating content, and
one guy generates a content with a key of 149, another guy Generates a
content with a key 148, 152, 153 and so on and
now what they want to do is they want to
place this key value pair this guy's node ID is
80. This guy's node ID is something else. Something else
something else and all these guys want to keep the
key value pair and what will they do in terms
of this greedy algorithm well they'll try to find a
node whose id is closest to the key that they
want to place. Well it turns out that 150 is
the closest. ID corresponding to all of these
keys that we're talking about here, so all of
these puts will result in going to one node, namely the node ID 150, in terms of
the put operation. And, first of all there's
going to be congestion here if a lot of.
Content hashed to a key that are so closely
together they all end up in the same node
ID 150. Remember that the actual content is
with the putter of this key value pair,
namely node 80. And, similarly, the content Is
with this putter, content with this putter. What
this guy is storing is the metadata that
allows everybody to discover the content provider. So
not only is this node going to find a lot of traffic if lots of keys map
to its node ID, also the nodes that are adjacent to this node In the overlay
network, they are going to be affected also.
Everybody is trying to reach this guy so you
can see that as we go towards this,
there's sort of a presaturation effect that's going
on. The tree is rooted at this destination
node, and the nodes that are in close proximity,
the intermediate nodes in the overlay network
space They get congested, and so on. And
that is what is sometimes referred to as a desaturation problem. Now this is for
the putters. Further, if my content whose
key value is toward here, the video that
I generated from my India trip. If that
gets hot, and everybody wants to Find out
how to achieve that particular video 149. They're
all going to make get calls. And these
get calls again end up with this same
metadata server, because that's the guy that is
storing my key value pair 149, 80. And so all these gets saying that I want to
get 149, I want to get 149, I want to get 149. All of them. Go to the same
node ID 150. Again there is congestion at the meta data so it can happen either
because some content is so popular that everybody
that wants to discover the content provider they
have only the key and they have to go to the metadata server to find out
the content provider So that results in this
congestion, which is the metadata server overload problem.
And the combination of these puts and gets result in what I
called the tree saturation problem, the tree being rooted at the congested node
and affecting all the nearby nodes In the overlay network because they
are the gateway to get this node that contains this particular key value pair.